all right
so the against
I am very happy to have you here with us
today for our College seminar at the
beginning of the year
the first visit
your first visit at our College was in
December 2020 in a completely different
world at that time it was the very first
time that a NATO Secretary General ever
came to the European college and it was
already a sign for our excellent
cooperation
since then our cooperation has only
deepened and grown and this is also
reflected in the new joint declaration
that we signed yesterday
so together we are now taking our
partnership to a next level
this happens of course against the
backdrop of an increasing geopolitical
competition
we know that our adversaries and our
competitors are using all possible tools
to challenge us
and to undermine our security they are
afraid of our openness of our
transparency of our democracies so they
will seek to exploit as much as possible
these values the openness and of course
they will try to exploit our
interdependencies
that's why it is so important that we
stand together and strengthen our
resilience overall
today at the college seminar we will be
discussing Russia's war of aggression
against Ukraine
it is now day
322 of the invasion and we will discuss
our support to Ukraine from the
humanitarian side to the economic side
to the security assistance
we will of course also reflect on the
consequences for European security
and we will discuss the potential
changes that are necessary in our
respective policies
seeing the backdrop of a security threat
in the European Union and the European
European region
for that we have for example to boost
our defense capabilities in Europe
because we all know that a stronger
European Defense will also make NATO
stronger
since the beginning of Russia's War
member states have started to increase
their military spending that's very good
but we do not only need to spend more
but we also need to spend better
this is important to avoid costly
fragmentation
it is important to ensure that there's
value for money
we need to build interoperable forces
that's the most important part and of
course to maintain a strong industrial
military base in Europe
we do already have the European Defense
fund which helps to develop cutting-edge
military Technologies and now we have to
make progress on The Joint Defense
procurement to harmonize that to have a
real common approach to that
but there's also another topic that we
will discuss that are the threats
against our critical infrastructure
this is one important it's a new Focus
for cooperation
and it is
the security of our infrastructure where
we have to step up the cooperation we
have seen the sabotage of North stream
that has shown that we need to be ready
and that we need to confront this new
type of threats so today we are
launching an EU NATO task force for
resilient critical infrastructure
this is a task force where our experts
from NATO and the European Union
will work hand in hand to identify key
threats to our critical infrastructure
to look at the Strategic vulnerabilities
that we do have
then of course also to develop key
principles to improve our resilience
and to propose mitigating measures and
remedial actions
the task force will at the beginning
cover four sectors that is transport it
is energy it is digital and space
and of course we will report back our
findings to the member states or the
Allies by now 23 if you count in Finland
and Sweden 23 member states of the 27 in
the European Union are also in NATO it
is about information sharing it is about
best practices of course it is about
early warning and shared expertise
but we will also discuss about other
areas of cooperation in short welcome to
the college seminar and I'm happy to
have you here
thank you so much
it's a great pleasure to be back and to
again be able to meet with the College
of Commissioners so it's uh it's really
a pleasure to have this opportunity for
the second time
our partnership the partnership between
the European Union and NATO is more
important than ever because Russia's
brutal invasion of Ukraine has
fundamentally changed our security in
recent days we have seen fears fighting
around bakmud and solidar in eastern
Ukraine
this shows Once Again The Bravery of
Ukrainian forces as they fight to defend
their Homeland
it also shows how vital it is that we
step up our support our military support
to Ukraine
are therefore welcome the recent
announcements by the United States
France and Germany and that they will
soon deliver infantry fighting vehicles
and light tanks and the unprecedented
support by all NATO allies and EU
members States
our support makes a real difference on
the ground
and at this key juncture of the war we
must do even more even faster
from the start of the conflict NATO and
the European Union have stood with
Ukraine and have stood together
just yesterday we signed a new joint
declaration you and I usla and the
president of the European Council
Charles Michelle
this will take the partnership between
NATO and the European Union to a new
level
in a world of growing geopolitical
competition we will address new areas
such as emerging and disruptive
Technologies
space and the security impact of climate
change
resilience and the protection of
critical infrastructure are a key part
to our joint efforts
as we have seen both with President
Putin's weaponizing of energy and as you
mentioned Ursula the sabotage of the
north stream Pipelines
so we have agreed to create a NATO EU
task force on resilience and critical
infrastructure
we want to look together at how to make
our critical infrastructure technology
and Supply chains a more resilient to
potential threats and to take action to
mitigate potential vulnerabilities this
will be an important step in making our
societies stronger and safer so there
Islam thank you again for your
invitation and thank you for your strong
commitment to strengthening the
partnership the cooperation between the
European Union and NATO thank you thank
you very much let's go
foreign
[Music]